all of us are dead isn't that a fact
season two episode two
guys if you could hit that like button
would very much appreciate it helps us
out in the algorithm he's trying to get
in that dos cavazos feed you know anywho
subscribe and click that notification
bell hopefully we'll wind up in that get
jaby feed after that hey check us out on
patreon massive thanks to all who have
become superjects today by checking out
all that crap we got to offer over there
hopefully i'm not following other
reactors who are covering this and uh
thanks to the boys of prepper for
helping us edit these down you guys
are okay gentlemen let's get to it
[Music]
meanwhile i'll take the coat off
use the cone as a weapon
[Laughter]
keep calm everybody
oh thank god he had that cone
oh he saved her good good
oh my goodness
oh she's turning she
damn that is some amazing zombie acting
wow
oh my god why can't one person bite him
this guy of all people
oh god
are they on the roof
or is the no the roof is higher okay
this is crazy there's nowhere to run
blast them do it
i imagine something different
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
well the amount of people fighting this
one room
insane this is where the resistance will
begin
good timing
oh no competition
oh good now i can get out of the world
i bet at that school they're like we
need to keep this an internal matter
[Laughter]
really really be careful as to how
[Laughter]
he did turn his son intentionally called
him right away
oh my god at least he caught this in 4k
yeah
dude you created the first zombie virus
come on that's something yourself a
little credit you brought fiction to
life
get in there expose your neck
oh are you doing this to yourself
it's trying to busan
oh
wow that is so fun
[Applause]
wow
oh really smart
it's a good try though
oh no they're gonna think it's a prank
called
now
come hose down the zombies
you know it's okay to call with like a
bit of panic in your voice to
literally alert them to the
violence that's occurring in your school
now we gotta keep up the social show
ready for that
way more
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
barricade the door why didn't we think
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah you know all these like rules about
council and student
nah man that's what keeps us sane
is this [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god guys cut his head off guys
bash his head as he in train to busan
[Music]
oh jesus
oh
no
just just cut the lower half of your
face off you'll be fine
oh
i just met you
and i already don't want you to die
[Music]
you don't all have to leave just get a
couple of them out yeah
dude
what is it oh
you are
we thought you had it covered man
[Music]
[Laughter]
go man do your thing
[Music]
watch your hands
[Music]
my dude's been waiting for this day
oh that's where the answers are yeah
defeat it with science
fire extinguisher is coming in clutch
today
oh no
oh [ __ ]
oh no
that's right i broke it
don't break more windows
what are you doing
i mean i know you're panicked but still
let me have a shot
everybody take turns
going shifts
[Laughter]
i keep playing out a scenario in my head
where they could have just lured out the
other two and they could have kept that
room
[Laughter]
oh now he's on a solo journey
he's like the wreck of the show
he's gonna come back with a beard
[Laughter]
and a son
carl carl carl
man you are the worst
i like her
yeah she's the badass this ensemble just
keeps getting bigger and
bigger it's gonna be the whole city by
the end of the show another school in
another school
oh
would have done the trick
how's your chance don't wait for her to
run at you yeah come on
okay wait for her to run are you
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
oh
[Music]
is contact your parents
good speech teach ah man stud muffins
out there somewhere
she's bleeding isn't she
oh i really liked her yeah i did too
[Music]
oh
that's so sad
we're gonna have to throw you out a
window
[Music]
oh
you gotta have glass in your gut now
[Music]
she was awesome
why don't you grab something to grab a
little bit of a like a piece of wood
hey perfect
damn it
that's annoying
[Laughter]
chocolate
decide everything with rock paper
scissors
be a lot harder climbing up huh yeah
half of them are going to fall
[Music]
my
me
just tell her
holy
am so worried this guy's not gonna make
it man
you're the most priceless work of art in
this room
ugh
no
[Music]
[Applause]
you gotta be [ __ ] me
tell me one of them broke his fall
that is so frustrating
[Music]
that is so frustrating yeah
although
we didn't see it happen
not that i think that matters in this
show but he didn't see it happen so
you never know
you never know
where would he have landed no idea
there's nothing really that i can think
of none of the shrubs below look strong
enough to break a fall from that height
without causing serious damage
i think if he was able to grab the hose
then he would have splattered against
the wall
but yeah that sucks yeah that's that
painful
that's annoying yeah
genuinely annoyed yeah like dude
come on for situations exactly like this
you tell her
wait you're annoyed that he didn't tell
her how you felt
that's what you were thinking
i mean not really i was more like
if they didn't waste any time if she if
she would just got on that rope earlier
he would have been going down that rope
yeah that's true absolutely damn you're
grieving
damn you having to process the loss of
your best friend
how dare you yeah
there's just two it's like everything
changed in the split of just a few
seconds
when it was like i'll go first no you go
first
and then they debated about that like
there's no time for debating
those seconds cost him
that's so frustrating
so annoying how a few seconds would have
changed everything
yeah unless he comes back and he's alive
in the next episode
again i don't expect it
and i feel like it would be really hard
to explain that in a way that doesn't
kind of undercut things but at the same
time we didn't see it happen so i just
i've learned never to
never to put too much talk into a death
i didn't actually get to watch
that was uh that was sad it was a good
one it was real tense tight episode it
was an hour over an hour long but it
flew by pretty fast
because it was just the zombie thrills
you got a good oner at the top at the
cafeteria which was cool to behold very
visceral intense
disgusting in all the right ways
wet
yeah
water and blood
love it lick it up keep referencing the
raid but it again reminded me of that
prison fight a little bit it's like how
how wet you feel watching it yeah it was
good man it was really well done
um
i think i know some of the casts
i mean that one girl is in squid game
for sure
yeah that's her character squid game
uh your character's background is you're
in squid gear
hey i mean everyone's wearing that
similar shade of green
uh you know i mean uh i forget the names
i call them stud muffin stuff muffin
yeah repressed boy who just died
girl
interest
best friend of girl
squid game
game i don't know any other the
characters uh
good lady who is the teacher this park i
know that's either one remember miss
park
this badass girl in the bathroom yeah
then we got that [ __ ] and oh badass girl
in the bathroom she was awesome she was
really a badass for sure so i'll be
killing
i loved her attitude the whole time yeah
it's just cold but you know she's
fighting the right fight and she knows
how to fight i like the introduction of
the archers too
that was wicked yeah i forgot they set
that up i think what they're doing
slowly is they're throwing not slowly
but quite fast actually it's throwing
you into the peril so much
and uh you know this outbreak of just
the this hive mind of all kinds of this
cacophony of just [ __ ]
and then they're introducing
slowly people who you can root for to
help save the day yeah
stud muffin
archers archers which is cool smoker
lady
so you have like those kind of badass
characters who can really hold their own
they did establish in stud muffin though
in the last episode how like he doesn't
fight anymore
and he would give up all the fighting
that meant but damn this guy knows how
to fight he's actually secretly 40 years
old it has
black belts in every elite style of
fighting
sometimes this uh
there's something about the quality of
this show that i really appreciate which
is they know what zombies are they
they've they've
been made privy to it through works of
fiction
and now they're experienced in real life
so what the show does as an audience
member is
challenge logic and reasoning
in times when you're like but i'm not in
their shoes so i'd probably make some
stupid choices too oh yeah and it's of a
panic
all of that armchair logic of why don't
you just do this yeah it goes out the
window it's really easy for me to
imagine doing a john wick type of
takedown against an army of men
but then i'm like ah but if i had to
kill a guy i don't know if i could
actually do it
you know so
it's the kind of thing where i'm like i
want to yell at the people
and then i go
it's because they know what zombies are
so i want to like kind of yell at them
and then i like ah but you know you
can't
you can't really blame bunch of
teenagers for having to deal with death
in front of their faces and then like
you can't like especially before
someone's turned and there's even that
part of you that i thought they handled
really well with that friend's death
that goes
uh they turn but maybe there's a chance
they did go back you know organizing of
these happy movies yeah or maybe it's
not gonna affect you as bad as it
affected everybody else yeah it's like
when it's someone you care a lot about
you you hope you can break through to
them you know
and i like i so i like that i do because
like the classroom scene at the top
or the first place they huddled together
i did find myself like getting
frustrated at like
just get the two people out
it's not that it's much easier than this
hallway door thing you got going on
inject it then i go oh no but you're in
a situation like that you probably want
to
like does it get the water this isn't
safe in here um yeah so you got that
or even being trapped in there and
wanting to get the fire hose like yes
things like that or
i have a really squid game ladies gonna
piss me the [ __ ] off as a shooter
she just seems like she just yells at
people yeah just like
i'm not really doing anything but i'm
gonna yell you're not doing something
yeah i'm gonna be rate everybody around
for not being competent while i just
make everything worse she really seems
like she's going to get on my nerves
yeah and get a lot of other people
killed probably probably she's the kind
of would throw you in front of someone
absolutely she would
and then you got the hospital thing too
that's crazy we're like watching the
journey of this one woman this one
zombie woman
who like infected
the school and now she's infecting the
hospital
then she's gonna go
to a church
and then she's going to go to a
mcdonald's and the starbucks she's going
to slide their party to
all these places concert hall protect
all of south korea yeah
and then move on to other areas of asia
eastern europe
there's one woman doing everything well
that's what i i really like is is yeah
it's like you don't really leave the
school much but you do for crucial
little moments like that and they've
tied a lot of the elements together
really nice like yeah i like that they
have a certain amount of awareness so
that when that scene comes around where
they actually call the police station i
thought that was handled pretty
conscientiously work first
you know you have the trope of zombie up
well that's in public ah we're gonna
laugh about this and then the hospital
call comes in and lends it credence and
i thought that was like really nicely
handled of like wait some shit's going
down to the hospital somebody's biting
people zombies uh and and just the way
that they like these two episodes yeah
they have that thing where it's like
you're watching essentially just a
series of zombie movies as a season of
tv
but at the same time what this feels
like it's doing is re this feels like
it's taking place in very real time
uh which i feel like is one of the most
unique aspects of it like it doesn't
seem like we're hopping around almost at
all in terms of
the point
from which we started you know we saw a
little bit of a flashback in the first
episode but like since it has hit the
school it's pretty much just been
where do we go next you know well school
settings cool yeah that's a really cool
setting to have this at yeah it's a
great containment spot you know i think
sometimes the best zombie movies are
ones that are just a locked off location
where they're trapped but it's big
enough where you can
run around still explore different
locations how do we get from this floor
to that floor
you know i think it's smart smart stuff
to toy with
but man
that phone call thing kind of aggravated
me yeah
he's like why are you calling in such a
calm manner
yeah just be like don't like scream
there are people murdering people that
are there
to say that there's a riot of people who
are biting and swiping at people
calling father firefighting dad like
just say that yeah there's like oh
there's riots and there's people being
murdered if you're if you like come to
your senses and go we can't say zombies
and your second call
infuse the packs people take your
situation seriously there is a crisis
and my voice denotes the crisis well
what
what was i think frustrating about it is
it didn't
seem
like uh
authentic within the moment how that
call was handled because i'm like nah
they'd probably panic you know a little
bit although they'd probably have like
anxiety while they're making this call
right yeah and then like it's already a
big deal when they're teenagers were
having to call the cops because they
didn't they didn't their anxiety wasn't
piercing through their call and so
that's why i was like what a weird
acting choice it just seemed like it was
like that for the comedy yeah and then
to have her on the other end be like
don't say zombie they're not gonna
believe that like it doesn't
and you know there's maybe it sounds
more urgent if you could actually speak
korean but yeah it did sound a little
bit like you know why hey
we could sound more credible yeah it
sounded
like a prank call
it almost felt like yeah they had it
sound less urgent to lend you know
credence to the guy's reaction which
isn't the best choice yes right out of a
whole hour and ten minutes that's the
takeaway that's all that's what's
important we got from it remember one
minute right there
oh oh and what's going on i'm excited to
see what horrible fate befalls the
scoundrel guy who's still in the
cafeteria or whatever that horrible
[ __ ] penis
i know like 10 zombies are gonna like
one zombie's gonna bite onto his penis
and then like one each on his butt
cheeks and then you know it's gonna tear
him apart from the bottom up
he sucks
yeah
he's a terrible character
that's you know what's that you feed the
woman to the zombies and that's like now
you just kind of made your presence more
of an alert of where you're hiding yeah
exactly are you gonna throw her across
like really
you should have thrown one of those
watermelons or something
um i don't get how they're hiding so
well there yeah it seems pretty exposed
i mean unless it's like all the water or
something is getting in the way of the
zombie smelling them as much but i don't
know that's just me
thinking about it and science dad what a
science dad man
it's not going well in interrogation
traded all for his son to stand up
against bullies that's right man
that's how this began
bullying's a real problem not just in
the united states of america but across
the world well suicide girl at the top
deck man i mean she's like freaking they
got the best hideout and she gets to
watch the everyone fall yeah oh what a
great to watch everyone burn she can be
she could be the devil in hell just
watching everyone burn oh man what a
great view of like especially when you
hate everyone yeah
yeah
his friends from seats to the massacre
that's good for her yeah man i mean you
know she's earned that
yeah she's earned the right to sit
around and watch the world crumble i'm
not trying to be a hero in a situation
like this
look out for myself
and only myself that's good
i don't know i feel like he would do
well in a zombie apocalypse
especially with those crucial elements
of time
yeah i'd really utilize my time
management
you would that would be the key as to
why you're a perfect person for the
zombie survival squad is because you
would keep everybody on track
you come and be like hey we can't argue
about this [ __ ] for too long
otherwise all of us are going to die one
of us is going to die we could prevent
this and just [ __ ] go
yeah man yeah
don't mess with me you know always on a
clock
yeah man
come in handy in the apocalypse the
apocalypse
look out
yeah
for those who made it this far that's
first
all right guys let's do a page
eric horstmann i didn't even check to
see if you're still pledged for the
month of february i'm just assuming
you're still pledged for the month of
february if you're not pledged for the
month of february i'm going into the
youtube editor and i'm deleting this
straight up stricken from the record
years of being our one of our highest
pledged patrons won't count for [ __ ] no
you think we're just gonna give you a
shout out out of the kindness of our
hearts if i open up the pledge manager
and go this guy on pledge for the first
time in a few years
wow you know after that whole
load of money millions of dollars he's
given us not no freebies around here
no shout out what have you done for me
lately
that's what i think you are as good as
the last thing you did the last pledge i
don't i don't factor in most any of what
you've done
i look at a singular last name not
collective it's not the quality of your
character it's the content of your
patreon pledge so eric um here's hoping
that this shout out counts for something
i think you would uh be frustrating and
apocalypse to be honest it would be
you would be fun if we were really
secure but the rest of the time i think
uh
i i think you might get us killed
if anyone's going to pick a fight
amongst the group is probably
but you know it'll be uh bring up like
other matters and subjects that are like
this isn't pertinent to
do the moment right now man we gotta
focus on surviving
society has long since crumbled okay
but either way uh yeah you know be nice
to have you around
happy february
go uh order a male prostitute to
split it up so that way youtube kind of
detects what i'll say yeah
male prostate
[Music]